[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the pace of grocery inflation eases to
its lowest monthly rate this year but
remains high at sixteen and a half
percent
mortgage rates continue to rise on a
daily basis as the number of products
available falls again
the Paris air show takes off with
billions of pounds worth of deals being
announced
plus the uk-based creative Studio behind
the new mascot for next year's European
football championships in Germany
[Music]
foreign
good morning this is in King live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City the pace of grocery
inflation has eased to its lowest
monthly rate this year according to
interest-free data qantar World panel
which tracks Supermarket sales and
prices reported a rate of 16 and a half
percent during the four weeks to the
11th of June it's the third month in a
row that the rate of price growth in the
sector has softened last month the
figure was 17.2 percent but the report
acknowledged that the rate remains high
with continuing pressures on households
and retailers you know if you look at
Iceland we've started by my mum and dad
in 1970 they've been through many many
trials and tribulations and and many
economic shocks but I don't think in our
53-year history we've ever had you know
such a perfect mix uh a perfectly
terrible mix of different factors you
know a lot of these issues are kind of
macro economic in nature post covered
recovery and very tight labor market
obviously and and indeed the war in
Ukraine and all of that is causing these
inflationary pressures and that's why
we're seeing food prices
um kind of 15 plus growth
I mean while mortgage rates are
continuing to rise the latest figures
from the data provider money facts
reveal that the average rate on a
two-year fixed rate mortgage is 6.07
percent that's up from 6.01 this time
yesterday with the average rate on a
five-year fixed rate deal is 5.72 that's
up from 5.67 yesterday and the number of
Residential Mortgage products has
continued to fall there are currently 4
641 Residential Mortgage products
available that's down from
4683 yesterday well joining me now is
Ray Bolger he's senior mortgage
technical advisor at John charcoal Ray
good to see you this morning um I mean
you've been that at this an awful long
time when did you last see market
conditions like this
well back in 2008 they were actually
worse than this because at that stage we
had lenders withdrawing mortgages and
not replacing them and it actually
became impossible to get a mortgage
unless you had a deposit of at least 15
so that situation was very different it
wasn't the case of rates going up it was
a case of actually not being able to get
a mortgage at all which is even worse
Ray when uh what are the mortgage
products most commonly being withdrawn
from the market right now
crates clearly are the most common
products some lenders offer three-year
fixes as well and some lenders off at 10
years but it is pretty well across the
board but it's going to be mainly two
and five year rates because that's where
most of the market is
once again I think is worth stressing is
that these average rates which the media
love coaching because they're an easy
thing to pick up for money facts each
day are actually coming to category what
I would call true but misleading if
you're looking for a new mortgage you're
not going to be looking for the average
rate you're going to be looking for the
best rate the average rate is going to
include lots of four rates which hardly
anybody's going to buy and even if
you've only got a five percent deposit
you can still get a two-year fixed rate
mortgage under six percent for example
despite the average being quoted as 6.07
so I think these averages
um you know do tend to be rather
misleading that's a very good point you
make Ray I mean it seems to me that a
lot of the products that are being
withdrawn right now are particularly on
high loan to value products is that a
fair assessment
now he's pretty well across the board a
few letters that do withdraw their High
loan to value products we've seen other
lenders who've actually kept their 95
LGB mortgages at the same level and put
the rate up on others so it depends on
what part of the market the lender wants
to focus on one of the things that is
very different in the market now
compared with say two years ago is that
the gap between rates for people with a
big deposit
so they were looking to borrow 60 and
those who are looking for a 95 two years
ago that was about three percent now
it's actually less than one percent so
you know it might be a small crown of
comfort for first-time buyers to know
that the rate they're having to pay
today hasn't gone up as much as for
people with a big deposit no mortgage
products are priced off something called
the swaps curve just for the uninitiated
can you explain how that works please
now what essentially swap rates aren't
priced off the guilt yield so
um if um if you keep an eye on guilt
rates which are easier to follow than
swap rates that's going to give you a
very clear pictures to what's going to
happen in the mortgage Market the swap
rates generally certainly for the
shorter periods like two and five years
which are the most common
um will be a little higher than guilt
yields and because lenders borrow money
in the in wholesale markets by doing
what's called a swap with a lender
because most lenders certainly the
mainstream lenders have have floating
rate money they've got money from
savings accounts they've got money from
current accounts and if they're going to
lend money on a fixed rate they need to
match the lending with the borrowing
otherwise they're at risk
um so that's a transaction in the
markets that lenders will do to offer
these six or eight mortgages and if a
lender's Treasury Department has been
very clever or very lucky and bought a
chunk of money before rates have gone up
that obviously allows them to stay in
the market with a competitive rate
forever longer than another lender that
might not have done that
and are you seeing much evidence of
mortgage products being withdrawn for
reasons other than the swap curve moving
against the mortgage lender and whether
their book is positioned
now it's pretty about all about the cost
of fun and so there's one or two of The
Specialist lenders sometimes we draw
from the market for a while because
they're funded in a different way but in
general for the majority of lenders
um if they pull products and we've seen
some of them come out of the market for
a day or so but in general they then
come back a day or two later so it's
much more about putting rates up rather
than actually having a smaller number of
products on the market now Michael Gove
the leveling up and housing secretary
has called for 25-year mortgages you're
smiling you know the question I'm going
to ask you Ray I mean is it a good idea
would it alleviate pressure
well Gordon Brown admission Professor
David miles to do a review of long-term
fish rate mortgages about 20 years ago
and nothing much happened as a result of
that review but we have had 25-year
fixed rate mortgages available at
different times in the UK and back in
November 2021 Kensington mortgages
launched fix for Life mortgages where
you could fix for up to 40 years and
back in those days you could have bought
a 30-year fixed rate mortgage in under
three percent and I bet there's a lot of
people now who wish they'd done that so
the big plus clearly with a long-term
fixed rate mortgage is that you know
exactly what you're going to pay for as
long as you've got the mortgage the
challenge for lenders is that borrowers
don't like being locked into a repayment
charges for too long now we have a new
lender called perenna who are planning
to launch in about six months time and
they're going to offer long-term fixed
rate mortgages that only have early
repayment charges for five years so that
address is that particular problem the
key is what rate they can offer them but
at the moment if anybody wants a
long-term fixed rate mortgage Kensington
are offering 30-year fixed rates up 5.65
providing you've got a 40 deposit so
they are in the market uh it's just that
very few people are prepared to pay the
slightly higher price for them or not
prepared to accept your repayment
charges
right it's always very informative
talking with you this morning thanks
very much indeed for joining me pleasure
our reminder that you can scan the QR
code on your screen right now to watch
the covert inquiry where the former
Chancellor George Osborne and the former
Chief medical officer Dame Sally Davis
are giving evidence today currently
asking answering questions it's the
former cabinet secretary Oliver lettwin
some other business news stories for you
now and China's Central Bank cut two of
its main interest rates today in an
attempt to stimulate the country's
economy The People's Bank of China cut
its one-year loan prime rate from 3.65
to 3.55 percent while the five-year loan
prime rate was reduced from 4.3 percent
to 4.2 percent they were the first such
reductions in 10 months and come amid
growing evidence that growth in the
world's second largest economy is
starting to stall after its rapid
unwinding of covid restrictions six
months ago well the rate Cuts followed
the unveiling of some tax breaks for
businesses last week which were expected
to be followed by other measures in due
course
the motor dealer Lookers has agreed to a
takeover by a Canadian buyer and a deal
valing at four at 465.4 million pounds
the company which owns 147 dealerships
covering 35 makes of car is being bought
by a business called Global Auto
Holdings Limited which is owned by Alpha
Auto Group a privately owned Canadian
car dealer Network well the deal first
reported last night by Sky City editor
Mark Kleinman is the latest in a series
of takeovers in the auto sector which
have seen the likes of Marshall Motors
being snapped up
the artificial intelligence race has
accelerated as meta claims to have
developed an ai2 convincing to release
to the public the Facebook parent
company says its voice box AI is capable
of creating a realistic sounding Voice
by feeding it just two seconds of speech
meta claims it will enable people to
talk to each other authentically even if
they don't speak the same language the
company has to date invested 36 billion
dollars in its metaverse program to
little return so far
now this week is the Paris air show at
the biggest and longest running
Aerospace trade show in the world
billions of dollars worth of deals are
being announced at the event which
brings together all of the major players
in the global Aerospace industry with
British businesses hoping to be
collecting a lot of them well among
those in attendance is ADS the UK trade
Association for the Aerospace security
defense and space sectors which is
hosting a United Kingdom Pavilion I've
been speaking to its chief executive
Kevin Craven and began by asking him
what the main talking points were at
this year's event
so clearly the drive to the green
technologies is the big theme of the
show together with the EV toll sector
electric taxis uh and advanced
immobility themes these are all things
that are really exciting things for our
sector and we're seeing quite a lot of
innovation and drive around that
how do you assess the progress being
made right now towards net zero Aviation
a huge amount of confidence in the
sector I think Ian it's really uh good
to see um the larger companies
committing with significant amounts of
resource and Manpower and Investments
and there is a huge degree of confidence
that the engineering is going to catch
up with the ambition uh shortly we're
still because these are Big programs
huge leaps in engineering required I'm
I'm still pretty sure that we're not
going to see uh commercial air flights
with sustainable Technologies until uh
2035 mid-30s but it's coming there's no
question about that
what about uh defense obviously that's
much in the spotlight since Russia
attacked Ukraine is is defense Aerospace
getting a lot more attention than in
previous air shows
yes I think that's probably fair to say
um certainly Ukraine has had an impact
on defense budgets around the world
that's still trickling through in terms
of orders but
um again driving Innovation at speed
where you've seen the Ukrainian industry
uh and their uh military working hand in
hand at the very uh front of the
battlefield to produce Innovation to to
counter some of the mess of the Russians
coming in
obviously civilization Aviation is
enjoying a big bounce back in activity
right now but what about capacity
constraints on the industry I mean
Boeing and Airbus have huge order books
right now that they're not going to
really uh fill for a number of years now
how concerned are you about that
well back order backlogs about 13 000
aircraft globally
um about seven years worth of production
we think and both Boeing an Airbus you
know doing a great deal of work on
ramping up the rates of manufacturing as
we speak I mean in the UK the sector's
worth about 27 billion uh pounds worth
of turnover generating around 11 billion
pounds evaluate to the UK economy so
going well I think and uh catching up on
the pandemic is going to take us
probably till mid to 2024 before we see
uh the sort of figures we saw in 2019
but it's coming back perhaps slower than
we might have expected but the inflation
cost of doing business kind of
challenges that our members are seeing
on a daily basis has probably not helped
that rate increase
we hear an awful lot about skill
shortages across the economy right now
and in particular uh workers aged
between 50 and 64 having dropped out of
the labor force altogether how has
Sierra space defense and space sector
coping with that
so we're seeing about 10 000 jobs uh
vacancies uh every month since 20 end of
2021 which aren't being filmed and
there's a real challenge in terms of
that we are seeing our Industries grow
the number of apprentices up 5200 now in
Aerospace but still got a long long way
to go and I genuinely believe that both
through technology perhaps AI might help
in terms of this perhaps through some of
the upskilling of our mid-level
workforces these are the types of
initiatives that need to happen in order
to fill those vacancies
I mean obviously this comes at a cost of
business I mean the likes of BAE Systems
produce many many hundreds of
apprenticeships every year how long
before the industry stops having to play
catch-up though in terms of upskilling
the workforce
I mean it's a great question I don't
know the answer to be honest Ian it
probably is going to take us I would say
four or five years If Ever I mean I
think it is just one of those uh
constraints and capacity that will
ultimately have to be uh caught up by
technology as opposed to the labor
skills of our Workforce
thank you
right here well Equity markets in the
Asia Pacific region had a largely
downbeat session that was off to the
People's Bank of China cut interest
rates by less than expected as you can
see the Hang sang in Hong Kong sold off
by one and a half percent and the
Shanghai composite by just under half of
one percent the main gainer in the
region overnight was in Australia stocks
their Rose after minutes from the latest
meeting of the Reserve Bank of Australia
pointed to keeping interest rates
unchanged they actually discussed that
during the meeting well in Europe stocks
have been largely in negative territory
this morning only the Ibex in Madrid in
positive territory right now among the
major Continental European indices
talking points this morning include the
German chemicals company Langs that
shares their dance on 15 in Frankfurt
following a profits warning well here in
London the ftse 100 is just about
holding its head above water it's more
or less unchanged quite quite frankly
mining heavyweights Weighing on the
index to an extent the leading Blue Chip
Gainer right now in percentage terms is
the Lloyds of London insurer Beasley the
shares there are hit by some two percent
that's after buying by its incoming
chairman Clive Bannister an old friend
of this program of course on the
downside ocado shares there down nearly
five percent that is on downbeat broker
comment I think JP Morgan casnova for
the uh culprits uh this morning outside
the footsie Saga the shares there are
just about ahead right now following the
trading update they were up half of one
percent the last time I looked well the
minor Greatland gold bit of a small uh
small cap favorite there among uh retail
punters the shares there some three
percent ahead on a drilling update on
the downside the recruitment specialist
S3 is off half of one percent after
warning of an uncertain macroeconomic
backdrop so the currency market so most
of the talk there has been on the Yuan
following China's rate cut which as I
said was less than expected the Yuan
trading now at a seven month low against
the US dollar back at level scene in
November last year Sterling is uh off
just under a sixth of one percent
against the US dollar dollar and buy a
fifth of one percent also against the
Euro single currency meanwhile more or
less I'll change right now against the
dollar it's been a quiet 48 hours for
the oil price uh it's been trading in a
very very uh tight band right now Baron
of Brent crude the last I looked I don't
know whether we can get it up on the
screen there uh we don't have it it lost
our check there it is
76.90 a barrel it will set you back
right and that's up for one percenter so
it's picked up a bit of momentum as the
morning has gone on well joining me this
morning is Alicia fourie she's a
consumer Analyst at investor let's see
good to see you this morning obviously
all eyes on inflation right now you've
got some interesting uh calls at your
shop right now on this yes that's right
I think the big Market moving piece of
news this week is of course the CPI
figure that's due tomorrow uh everyone
is expecting it to start to nudge down
because energy costs have started to
fall and it is now starting to feed into
that piece so the direction is hopefully
down which would be positive for the
market at investec we're actually
expecting a bigger fall than consensus
is looking for so our economists are
forecasting 8.2 percent the market is
looking for 8.5 percent now of course
those numbers are still very high
um and the UK inflationary environment
has proved incredibly sticky uh in the
last few quarters so there are lots of
reasons driving that so what are your
colleagues seeing that the rest of the
market isn't well I think what they're
looking at is you've got Commodities
coming down you've got shipping costs
have fallen energy costs have come down
and actually as
interest rates continue to rise and some
more mortgages start to
be re-fixed at higher rates it's been a
slower process here in the UK than it
has been in other parts of Europe so
when that starts to feed through that
all starts to put the brakes on
inflation just a bit so I think we are
also hearing this from consumer
companies too it's not just the investec
economists who have this view consumer
companies are expecting inflation to
ease in the second half for all those
reasons that I just mentioned
Commodities shipping costs energy and in
fact they're expecting a margin
potential uplifts in H2 of this year and
for commodity inflation to turn into a
deflationary Tailwind early next year so
it there is light at the end of the
tunnel but the number tomorrow will
still probably look pretty high what's
interesting about the consumer goods
universe is that there are pockets of it
that are still doing particularly well I
mean luxury goods being the obvious
example how easy is it to get a handle
on the extent to which households are
running down the enforced savings that
they built up during the pandemic period
yeah that that's uh that's a great
question in the UK the consumer is
actually sitting still on quite a
healthy level of covid savings excess
savings that were accumulated during
covid in other markets such as the US
and in Europe those have been run down a
lot faster
so the UK has a bit more cushion left we
are hearing not just in the UK but
around the world that consumers are
shifting towards high-end purchases that
trade-up phenomenon is still very much
alive despite inflationary pressures on
disposable incomes but also for those
consumers who are stretched
the lower price tier is also doing well
it's that middle range that middle
mid-priced food beverage household
products that's getting squeezed and in
fact that's exactly the pattern that we
saw the last time we had a big commodity
Spike back in 2011 the middle got
squeezed the top and bottom did very
well that's a very interesting time in
your sector more broadly because you've
got a lot of the big names Unilever
record diagio all with changes at uh at
the top right now yes and I think that's
one of the reasons why the investors
that I speak to are remaining nervous
about the consumer sector despite the
fact that these companies have upgraded
guidance earlier this year and as I said
H2 looks a lot more benign for them
inflation wise but yes there's a lot of
change happening you have diagio b-a-t
Unilever record all having changes to
the executive management team in in the
last few quarters and there's I think a
bit of uncertainty out there in in the
investor
in the investor Market where they're
worried about you know what's the
Strategic direction of these companies
will there be any change as a result of
these these moves so I think they're
that's one of the reasons why despite
good underlying fundamentals and good
prospects for the sector why the shares
haven't moved very much this year
alrighty let's see it very good to see
you this morning thanks for joining me
thanks
still to come here on Ian King life the
future of financial Tech in Africa
[Music]
if you look at his consistency for
releasing music it's unbelievable if you
go out to 2011 he released his debut
album he's released six records since
then I think the first couple were three
years apart now it's two years apart in
the meantime there are EPS reversions of
tracks where he's happened to get
Beyonce to jump on one and this kind of
thing tours and I think you just look at
that period of time he's obviously a
massive charting artist but the fact
that he keeps coming back with such
consistency is is quite staggering
really and the way that this survey this
is PPL so it's not only it's music that
you've you've chosen to stream or heard
on the radio this is stuff you might
hear in a cafe always performed at a
festival and so so the fact that the
music is out there it sort of lives on
playlists then he releases some more
music that adds to playlist so you might
never engage with an engineering record
but the chance so you probably will hear
one of his songs because of the there's
so much of it available you know I
personally I'm not the biggest fan but I
will say he does run the gamut he does
do you know he's number six
collaboration project was a bit more out
there in terms of the people he worked
with he will do sort of you know quite
quite friendly chart stuff some very
lovely dovey stuff which which you can
see working really well in that kind of
space but I think to be fair to him with
with every record he has done he has
sort of pushed what he does a little bit
what's interesting is the way they've
without plus minus divide equals
subtract uh album stream that he has
kept this sort of very strong brand
identity and I think that really helps
the big mainstream audiences because you
sort of just know it's Ed Sheeran you
don't he's not changing the album cover
every time you can sort of go oh he's
back I know what that is just by looking
at you know a mathematical symbol there
he missed out because I mean Harry's
house came out in May last year so I
thought he probably would have been
quite close I thought he might have
beaten Ed Sheeran but again I think it's
just Ed has that back catalog in terms
of being the artist of the year I mean
obviously Harry's living in Wembley
Stadium at the moment so who knows
financially it might be a title
all right
welcome back now this week we'll see
more than 2 000 experts and Business
Leaders descend on the Rwandan capital
of Kigali for what its organizers claim
will be one of the biggest fintech
events this year in the world and
certainly the largest in Africa the
inclusive fintech forum is aimed at
capitalizing on the fintech boom
currently underway in the continent with
the sector in Africa growing at around
10 a year Well joining me now live from
Kigali is Dengue Chief Operating Officer
at Rwanda Finance limited Orton's very
good to see you this morning why is
fintech going through such a a strong
period of growth in Africa
yes so good morning Ian and uh pleasure
to be with you this morning on the show
um we're very very happy and we're
having an exciting morning here in
Rwanda and we have over 2 500 500
delegates that have actually convened to
discuss the whole topic that is
filtering Financial inclusion and uh
Financial technology is actually the
fastest growing industry in the
community services
our financial services sector is seeing
a 10 percent annual growth right and
financial technology is actually the
driver behind that so we are
anticipating that this will transform
economic development on the continent
and we're excited to be hosting this
forum to be able to convene all the key
players you know on the market whether
Regulators to to discuss you know the
possibilities of creating more
regulations of policies that are
conducive to boost fintech uh
development into the continent and we're
also excited to see startups right and
entrepreneurs here today also joining us
in this conversation to be able to see
what solutions they can offer us today
that we face on the continent you know
with the percentages of you know high
level of advanced population that's a
big opportunity but we think that uh
fintechs are either going to play and
also one of the key drivers behind why
feed Tech is becoming a boom on the
continent is because there's still great
need and opportunity to accelerate
Financial inclusion and that's really
where I find interesting
check your role and we're excited to be
having the conversation and seeing
really what key takeaways we can take
from this to further that composition
you've just put your finger on a really
important point though I mean mobile
money in particular has grown very
rapidly in Africa in recent years why is
it then that so many Africans remain
unbanked
yes uh and it's a great question there
Ian absolutely mobile digital payments
have actually scaled to the room uh when
you talk about uh pool Tech or the
really the biggest segment in terms of
products that have really taken up has
been in mobile services digital payments
primarily as well as e-wallets and we're
also seeing that it has been yes
relegated Justice some of the urban
areas and there is need to increase
expansion and scale into the more rural
areas and I believe the biggest
challenge right now which is even the
biggest conversation today that we'll be
talking
is the need for more infrastructure
there is to be put in place that will be
able to give that access you know to the
rural population of the Unbound to be
able to tap into the conversation around
creating more services right uh that
will be able to enable uh cost
Effectiveness whether in terms of
internet for example to allow people to
be able to access these Digital Services
and so the conversation here really and
that's the important reason why we have
policy makers also joining us today is
to discuss you know what we're doing as
a continent and what we're doing as a
region you know we have the African
Continental free trade area for example
that is looking expensively or digital
payment system which is one of the areas
that will really allow for that access
you know increased access to financial
services
Beyond even what currency the mobile
service providers are able to offer it
will be an opportunity not to either
more players to be able to scale
um web access and also internally with
different jurisdiction it's a
conversation of what more can be done in
terms of human through that enacting
environment to attract more investment
into this infrastructure that can be put
together and put towards actually
advancing
um access to financial services
Orton's good to talk to you this morning
thanks for joining me
thank you
a bit of breaking news to bring you uh
we've just learned that French
investigators are searching the
headquarters of the 2024 Paris Olympics
organizers as part of an investigation
into suspected corruption we'll have
more on that for you as we get it in the
meantime still to come here on Ian King
live the UK based creative Studio behind
the new mascot for next year's European
football championships in Germany don't
go away
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s have been made for 3D printing
technology and the latest is that it can
be used to reduce the cost of space
launches Sky Roar based in cumbernauld
in North lanarkshire has begun testing
engines that have been produced using 3D
printing technology it claims the
engines which are powered by combustion
system run on a propellant combination
of hydrogen peroxide and kerosene can be
manufactured approximately 66 faster at
a 20 cost reduction we're joining me now
is Dr Jack James Marlow head of
engineering at Sky Roar uh welcome to
you what is the approximate concern of
producing these engines now
and while we've reduced it by around 20
so this is due to our in-house 3D
printing capabilities what we call the
sky print 2. so as we're going through
with our developmental campaign we've
done about 20 tests so far and then we
start to integrate 3D printing into that
engine and what we've seen is we can
reduce the cost by about 20 and also
speed up production which also brings in
its own cost reductions by about 66 and
this is by a hybrid of printing and then
also Machining on the same printer so
we're calling it hybrid 3D printer
now you've tweaked the design somewhat I
gather what have you done
so we basically Incorporated the CNC
machine with normal 3D printing and we
went with a different type of method of
3D printing called DED Direct Energy
deposition this means we can really
print the engine a lot quicker so
normally an engine would take about
three months to manufacture using normal
supply chain but now we can do it in one
month period
now you mentioned the uh tests these are
conducted I assume under the auspices of
the CAA are they
yes so we're regulated by the CAA
everything from our launch license to
our business operations and we have our
own test sites which is what the largest
test site in the UK test number engines
and one of the first since the 50 years
ago since the black Harbor program what
we can see on the screen now so we test
all our Center kilonewton engines right
there we've done about 20 so far and we
can see one on the screen now and we've
just came and finalized version one and
we've now upgraded the engine I went on
to version two so we've made it a bit
lighter also manufactured a lot quicker
and you might ask well why is it a great
benefit to manufacture engines a lot
quicker well on our first stage we use
nine of these on our first date so the
quicker we can build the more of us we
can build per year and then the more
satellites we can launch per year and
how many tests have to be run before the
CAA gives you sign off
and they don't fully regulate in terms
of the qualification campaign we use Esa
standards and normally it's around 50
tests and we're looking for a total life
cycle in terms of air time on an engine
but in our own in-house qualification
we've got about 50 tests I'm about 50 of
the week through and we're looking to
finish at around Q4 November this year
and that will be the first qualified
stage combustion engine in the UK ever
and assuming all the tests go to plan I
mean what happens after that
so that's a very good question once you
finalize qualification on the engine
what's basically the warehous of our
whole launch vehicle we integrate it
with the first stage and that's where we
put nine of them together we then
basically strap it down and we do a full
static fire test once that's done then
we can integrate with a space port and
then we proceed to Launch
very good to see you this morning thanks
very much you leave for joining me
thank you very much Ian for having me on
a qualification for Euro 2024 in Germany
is well underway with somewhat mixed
results last night for some of the home
Nations as well as a home win today
though for a london-based creative
Studio A toykido which has designed
uefa's Muscat for the tournament the
mascot a teddy bear is being unveiled
today with fans being asked to vote on
its name and it will feature in a
collaboration with toikido's Roblox game
pinata smash things which will include a
Euro 2024 football Island who are
joining me now is Darren Graham he's the
chief executive of toikido uh welcome to
you how did you win the contract the
competition must be quite intense yeah
well thank you very much thank you for
getting our name right that's always a
stumbler
um yeah we were very lucky we're
approached by Fanatics uh who are
handling the whole process a number of
companies went in for it
um we were lucky to come through with it
I guess a very creative team
um very fast as well I think one of the
during the process I think one of the
things they liked was our speed of
turning things around
um within hours 24 hours and I'm quite
surprised you I mentioned the fact that
you've got this new game on Roblox
coming up I'm surprised that you're
being allowed to incorporate the mascot
into it because I would assume that UEFA
have all sorts of uh you know
Protections in place you know what I
think that was one of the attractive
things as us as a business is that we we
have that link of digital and physical
um so as part of our pitch we offered to
put their experience within our world
um our game launches
um in a couple of weeks time which gives
us a year until the tournament launches
um so we'll have sort of an audio a
ready-made audience for the tournament
and for their fans as we go and then
really concentrating on the offline
piece as well one of the objectives for
UEFA was to be able to have this
physical experience but also have that
offline piece as well and as a dad of
three boys as a dad of three boys I know
how important that piece is as well yeah
absolutely why did you choose roadblocks
as the platform for this game yes good
question uh I mean it's it's definitely
the the fastest growing platform out
there at the moment soikido is a studio
we make games in on Steam in fortnite
um and other platforms Nintendo switch
but Roblox is frankly where my children
are uh playing at the moment I know
where their pocket money is spent at the
moment
um so it's just and I also like the the
factors as a as a platform the community
that the kids are there all around the
world playing together was very
attractive to us yeah are you gonna are
more games planned in in Roblox uh
platform yeah absolutely yeah as a
studio
um I mean toikido I want us to be the
the fastest and and best creative studio
in the UK so we have seven other IP in
development at the moment
um taking them from a digital platform
into toys and into other merchandise as
well as live experiences and music do
you see uh the fact that you've got the
mascot in a virtual setting does that
translate to Stronger physical sales of
toys and memorabilia than would have
otherwise been the case do you think oh
well I think potentially yes I think one
one of the things if you look at the
tournaments historically the majority of
the the merchandise that has been sold
from a tournament has been in the home
nation I think that we the fact that
we're putting it in a platform that has
a global appeal
um and pinata smash things which by
Nature has a global appeal we're
actually launching physical merchandise
in 70 countries from this September so
we'll have a global footprint for the
brand itself
as UEFA comes into us next year and when
you were designing the mascot did you
have any sort of what was the the spec
from UEFA if you like did they say it
had to be a teddy bear or was that your
idea uh no that was our creative team I
mean UEFA wanted a bear of sorts uh I
mean obviously the the Germany and the
bear
um come hand in hand if you look at
stipend and those other amazing
companies
um but from from our side it also makes
it a lot more commercial as well I think
if you look at the mascots
let's not say too much about the
Olympics uh 2012 but but I know that
sort of uh partners of friends are
buying that were involved in that still
have a lot of product left yeah from
those mascots
um so I think the the bear that we've
created will will hopefully not have
that effect it's funny I mean some of
them really do live in the memory I mean
I always think of the little orange from
the 1982 World Cup in Spain and things
like that what makes us a mascot
successful oh do you know what I mean
Mexico 86 is mine
um I mean that that really sticks with
me I think you have to look at where the
trends are I think you have to look at
the audience I mean the the way that we
made the bear very physical and as you
see content as it as it comes out and is
revealed
um it you can really have a lot of fun
with that there in terms of the physical
aspects on and off Pitch and on and off
the game I presume that by the way it's
being designed by the way so some poor
person is going to have to dress up as a
giant one and run around all the pitches
in the in the matches I am Anthony uh
Anthony rule who uh designed it for us
he designed it perfectly thinking about
the mascot in mind and John I think
that's one of the things maybe why we
leaned into this Fanatics UA for
opportunity was that we did look at the
Off mascot appeal and how it could be
used in other areas but yeah it's if
you're um if you're under six foot you
can get into that mascot I'm afraid
they'll fit into that category good to
see you this morning thank you cheers
[Music]
well time for look now at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with a story
that we brought you this time yesterday
the cost of a two-year fixed rate
mortgage deal in the United Kingdom
Rising above six percent or inside the
Ft there's a big right through by its
economics editor Chris Giles he writes
at another interest rate right from the
bank of England is now being fully
priced in by the markets of course
that's expected to see interest rates
rising from four and a half percent to
four and three-quarter percent well the
Ft also reports on its front page
yesterday's unexpected trading update
from next in which the retailer said
annual pay rises in April had lifted
household incomes and encouraged
customers to spend more on their summer
wardrobes the times leads its business
pages with news that the hedge fund
manager Crispin Odie has lost his status
as a fit and proper individual in the
city of London that of course follows
recent allegations of sexual misconduct
against him the times also reports on
its business front page that the John
Lewis partnership has written down the
value of its head offices by 15.6
million Pounds meanwhile The Daily
Telegraph leads its business pages with
news the bank of England officials
launching a new stress test to measure
the resilience of banks Pension funds
and other institutions to a sell-off in
the bond market it also reports that
Susan Davey the chief executive of
Southwest water's parent company panel
group has given up 440 000 pounds worth
of bonuses in the wake of record water
quality Vines for the company
no time for a paper reviewer today but a
reminder to you to check out the inking
live podcast which you can find by
scanning the QR code on your screen now
it's available now wherever you get your
podcast including the Sky News app Apple
and Google podcasts and Spotify
now Richie sunac spoke recently about
his ambition for the UK to become a
leading player in the global regulation
of artificial intelligence but the
European Parliament is already on route
to becoming the world's first regulator
of AI yesterday it passed a draft
regulation known as the AI act which
would Place new restrictions on how the
technology is used what you want to me
now is kriti Sharma Chief product
officer of legal Tech at Thomson Reuters
critic good to see you this morning
what's the European Parliament trying to
achieve here well they are really
looking at creating the first draft that
controls and teams AI in how we use it
ranging from very high risk or
unacceptable risk environments like
using it for predictive policing or in
certain situations where it really
should be banned all the way to some
risks that are acceptable for businesses
to really drive impact in adopt AI but
do it in a safe way and I really think
this is a great first step forward in
creating more transparency and more
trustworthy AI why was the European
Parliament so quick out of the blocks I
I think they've really got a lot of the
foundations in place and understanding
the impact on business on Innovation and
the EU does tend to be more of the
Leading Edge of creating regulation in
this case what's also really fascinating
is is that description of so-called
Foundation AI models many of which are
in public use now like Chad GPT and
they're creating clear guidelines like
for example not using copyrighted law or
content to produce disinformation or
misinformation or fake news kind of
examples so I think they're doing a
really good job at establishing
boundaries and creating Frameworks so
companies like ours have something to
work with within and it's not left to
individuals to figure it out yeah they I
mean they do really have to strike a
fine balance I mean on the one hand
they're going to be aware of the the
risks posed by AI technology but at the
same time they've got to be recognizing
that there are a lot of opportunities
that come with it I I think the there is
absolute consensus in the business
community that the best way to drive
adoption of AI is by making it
trustworthy and safe to do so so there's
Real Alignment and creating policies and
Frameworks and regulations around that
are really welcomed by most large
companies that we're seeing already
right the um the challenge however is
there's not enough consensus
internationally in how to create Global
standards the EU is going to take a lead
and they will get there faster probably
in a couple years even after passing the
draft law but now we need to create
Frameworks that apply to UK businesses
to the US and elsewhere in the world
absolutely now you had something called
AI for good what does that involved
building yeah I forget
pretty much what it says on the 10. it's
really about
really about create more
questions that are for good of the
society and and moving into areas by
supporting users usage of AI in
promoting access to Justice access to
financial inclusion and Health Systems I
really genuinely believe that the future
is going to be much more positive and
use if you use AI in the right way to
solve the right problems and also be
more intentional about who creates this
technology can't just be left to a small
number of people when there's amazing
talent and skills available around the
world how do you steer the conversation
away from the the quite real concerns
that people have that this is going to
take away jobs
um so there is going to be a real
redesign of roles and skills are going
to be needed in a completely different
way in the future I don't think it's a
conversation of steering away from the
job question it's more conversational
what are the new jobs that are going to
be created how to be upskill Talent this
huge amount of human potential that that
currently exists a lot of skills that
machines just don't have and so I think
the conversation absolutely happened
needs to happen more directly and
perhaps a call to the Prime Minister
that we should start focusing more on
real action around skills and new new
Talent Development where does the
European parliament's initiative sit
with Richie sunax Ambitions I mean it
looks as though the EU has stolen a
march on not only the UK but the United
States and other countries like China
yeah like I said there is concern
there is also quite a lot of intentional
conflict or Divergent views in how might
we do that so when we see the European
commercial European Parliament they're
taking a more direct approach a
risk-based approach high risk
unacceptable risk low low risk
applications we have the UK that has
historically taken more of a lightweight
light touch approach to AI and now we're
getting to a point where we need to
create more standard Frameworks that
apply so as a business when you're doing
business within the EU you're working
with International customers the law
applies to everyone wherever you're
building that service that impacts you
you need to have a framework that lets
you move forward and innovate and drive
the community and the economy forward
and not be bogged down by by various
different streams so I think the
opportunity for the UK really is to
bring the global Community together from
across the different spectrums of the EU
really leading the way here to the US
this is really starting to figure out
what the tech policy and a lot of tech
Innovation is coming from and other
parts of the world so there's a gap it
needs to be filled it needs to be filled
responsibly and it needs to be filled
fast fingers crossed critical guitar
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live it's
not just about the cricket for Australia
at the moment it's the tourism industry
prepares for a big Boost from the
women's football World Cup next month
don't go away
[Music]
everybody
if you look at his consistency for
releasing music it's unbelievable if you
go out to 2011 he released his debut
album he's released six records since
then I think the first couple were three
years apart now it's two years apart in
the meantime there are EPS reversions of
tracks where he's happy to get Beyonce
to jump on one and this kind of thing
tours and I think you just look at that
period of time he's obviously a massive
charting artist but the fact that he
keeps coming back with such consistency
is is quite staggering really and the
way that this survey this is PPL so it's
not only it's music that you've you've
chosen to stream or heard on the radio
this is stuff you might hear in a cafe
always performed at a festival and so so
the fact that the music is out there it
sort of lives on playlists then he
releases some normal music that adds to
playlists so you might never engage with
an engineering record but the chance
though you probably will hear one of his
songs because of the there's so much of
it available you know I personally I'm
not the biggest fan but I will say he
does run a gamut he does do you know his
number six collaboration project was a
bit more out there in terms of the
people he worked with he will do sort of
you know quite quite friendly chart
stuff some very lovely dovey stuff which
which you can see working really were in
that kind of space but I think to be
fair Tim with with every record he has
done he has sort of pushed what he does
a little bit what's interesting is the
way they've without plus minus divide
equals subtract uh album stream that he
has kept this sort of very strong brand
identity and I think that really helps
big mainstream audiences could you sort
of just know it's Ed Sheeran you don't
he's not changing the album cover every
time you can sort of go oh he's back I
know what that is just by looking at you
know a mathematical symbol though he
missed out because I mean Harry's house
came out in May last year so I thought
he probably would have been quite close
I thought he might have beaten Ed
Sheeran but again I think it's just dead
has that back catalog in terms of being
the artist of the year I mean obviously
Harry's living in Wembley Stadium at the
moment so who knows financially it might
be a tight around
[Music]
foreign
welcome back just a bit of breaking news
to bring you in the last few moments
valo calacane who is the person accused
of the attacks in Nottingham last week
has appeared in Nottingham Crown Court
and has been remanded in custody a trial
date has been set for the 12th of
January next year
now all eyes will be on edgebaston today
for what is expected to be a thrilling
conclusion to the first Ash's test but
for Australia in particular this is just
the start of a very busy sporting summer
in a month's time the Women's World Cup
begins Down Under the first time it's
been played in the Southern Hemisphere
and that's just the start of a series of
big sporting events being held in
Australia over the next decade or
joining me now is Sally cope she's
Regional general manager for the UK and
Northern Europe for Tourism Australia
Sally welcome to you
um does Australia really need all these
sporting events to sell itself I mean
it's got plenty of attractions on its
own merits sporting events like this
create such an amazing opportunity for
us Tourism Australia is the marketing
Organization for visit encouraging
visitors to come down to the country and
something like the FIFA Women's World
Cup uh where I think FIFA are expecting
around uh two billion people to be
watching the tournament over the course
of the um of the tournament is a great
opportunity for us to just leverage all
of those people watching and show the
beauty of the country and which are the
other big events coming up over the next
decade that you're excited well we're
calling it Australia's decade of green
and gold so out of this region we're
excited because the obviously the ashes
will be back in 25 and the rugby lines
are coming down in 25 as well but as far
as World Cups go we have the rugby men's
in 27 the rugby women's in 29 the
Commonwealth Games are down there in 26
and it's all culminating to the Olympic
Games and the paralympic games in
Brisbane in 32 so decade of green and
gold very very busy time in Australia
only reopened to foreign visitors in in
February what have the numbers been like
we've seen a real bump especially from
this region so uh I think initially it
was an indication of the strong ties
between Australia and the UK people
returning to visit friends and family
but now the true holiday makers are
coming so when you've got a sporting
event like this it's perfect timing for
us I think when broadcasters will be
talking about about the sporting
highlights we'll be talking about the
holiday highlights at the same time I
mean prior to the pandemic I think the
UK was fourth in terms of importance
behind the US New Zealand and China does
that remain the case right now it's
number two on visitation but I think
that's because the China Market is only
opening now so we're launching our
Global come and say good day campaign in
China next week we've managed to do that
much earlier in October last year here
in the UK and it's really building
momentum which is great and you've also
waived the cost of working the holiday
visas for young britons uh well what's
happening it's really presenting a lot
of opportunities on the 1st of July this
year the age range is increasing from 30
to 35 so young is getting a little bit
older and then next year on the first of
July it will be much more flexible
around getting second and third year
visas there won't be restrictions on
where you work and so on so great
opportunity for young people to go and
experience the Aussie lifestyle what was
the thinking behind that I present
because Australia's Got just as tight to
labor market as we have in this country
there is that so from a tourism industry
perspective we're excited because
Backpackers and working holiday makers
provide an amazing seasonal Workforce
they're traveling and working to extend
their trip so it's really great for
regional Australia so I've got to ask
you who's going to win the first test
today
it's close I think all I can say is the
ashes is going to be a great
um you know series because they're so
evenly matched but of course I'm going
for the Aussie I wouldn't expect
anything else to be Sally I was at the
carbine Club lunch in London yesterday a
great event uh you know full of
anglo-australian camaraderie banter yeah
continue yeah Jeff Thompson and uh Jeff
oh brilliant yeah Sally go leave it
there good to see you this morning thank
you
that's it from me for today there's much
more on the Sky News Mobile app and on
the website with reporting video content
and Analysis from our business team I'm
back at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning hope
very much to see you then do stay tuned
after this short break Wilfred Frost
will be up with all the latest from the
covert inquiry where as we speak the
former Chancellor George Osborne has
started to give evidence a lot more on
that at the top of the hour see you
tomorrow thanks for joining me today
cheerio
[Music]
thank you